all right guys let's dive in
this is the official retro wreck into a
reaction to the brand new hogwarts
legacy dark trailer
all right let's do this man i've waited
long enough let's dive in
more we know about salazar slytherin and
the dark arts the best preparations will
be the 4k quality if either of you uses
dark magic i will notify the headmaster
immediately
hmm
unforgivable curses are so named
for a reason uh oh oh save your life
shouldn't be unforgivable
the dark hearts seem harmless until it's
too late
none of us will be able to avoid dark
magic forever
what do we do now
it's up to us i can teach you crucio
or i can cast it on you
what
i'm ready
it made you a choice
well there we go
there we go
another unforgivable
confirmed
dude that looked like the door looked
like chamber of secrets obviously not
the chamber but
oh my gosh
i guess she went along with it
[Music]
oh
dark arts pack pre-order digital deluxe
edition
okay looks like we
pre-order on august 25th okay yeah so i
did see the announcement about that
i did see that announcement
oh my goodness
dude that was that really one minute and
50 seconds that flew by
that was just
that flew by too quick
we were spoiled man after the big 14
minute reveal okay
all right
so
crucio confirmed seemingly
and just a very dark
very dark trailer right there